billy nice to see you there national
border patrol council president brandon
judge sir good morning to you
ron klain on sunday kind of explained it
this way all right about title 42 cdc
watch
title 42 isn't an immigration law it's a
public health law it says you can
exclude people
who pose a public health risk the
centers for disease control decide uh
how to apply that and they've decided
that sometime in late may the pandemic
will be a place where we can no longer
exclude people on a public health
rationale so
the number i have is 1.7 million
expelled under title 42.
you take that away and how many do you
have sir
bill it's going to be astronomical we
just don't we don't have the resources
to deal with what we're seeing right now
let alone once title 42 goes away i
can't tell you how ticked off we are as
agents we cannot do the job that we're
supposed to be doing we can't control
what the flow that's coming in at 3 000
people we can barely do the job five
thousand people it's a crisis just last
week we had days where we hit eight
thousand people and it's expected to go
up to eighteen thousand
we are pulling people off the border for
stretches of two hundred miles 200 miles
are completely and totally unpatrolled
at any given point in time we can't do
the job based upon what this
administration is doing with its policy
sir why do you think that this
administration has allowed virtually an
open border
i believe that they're trying to change
the demographics of the electorate
that's what i believe that they're doing
they know they want to stay in power and
the only way to stay in power is to
continue to get elected they can't get
elected on their policies because their
policies are bad
cynically could you argue that title 42
the way it was in place was since the
administration chose not to get control
of this border that you could use that
that that order from the cdc to turn
people back
and that was your measure of control in
the southwest you understand that
yeah and there's there's several things
that this administration can do if they
want to get rid of title 42 that's fine
re-implement mpp you already have a
court order telling you that you have to
do it yet they're only enrolling about
nine people per day in their micro
protection protocols if we go back to
policies that have worked and and there
are policies that have worked we don't
even have to pass this burden onto the
taxpayer we don't need more
infrastructure we don't need more
resources we don't need more technology
we need policy and that's something this
administration could give us and they
refuse to do it one last point here the
number of ukrainians i'm told seeking
asylum grows by the day uh you make the
point that the cartels won't touch the
ukrainians
well th this is this is how
sophisticated
this organized crime is they understand
that the the politics of it if they were
to force ukrainians to cross the border
illegally and pay them the fees then you
would have a bunch of public outcry
around the world not just here in the
united states but around the world these
cartels understand the politics the ebbs
and flows and they will not touch the
ukraine they they have them go through
the ports of entry which is a legal
process very interesting brandon judd
thank you nice to see you again all
right thanks for coming in bill hi i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now